oh
man it's early i just woke up actually
much later than normal
8 38 am
yesterday at the office we were
reviewing the packaging design of young
gun season two and it was interesting to
see the results that came out of there
they had two weeks to work on it
and one of the pieces of feedback that
we got from them was that
it wasn't enough time
two weeks wasn't enough time
and i was thinking to myself shoot
two weeks is a lot of time i was just
thinking is this something that i could
do in a day
so what i want to do is i want to take
on the young gun season 2 packaging
design challenge and see if i can
complete it
within the whole day today
there are some other things that are
going on that i have to take care of
also
disclaimer you know i've been a creative
professional for 15 years now but i'm no
professional packaging designer not at
all the thing is i don't really design a
whole lot these days however i think i
can do it
so let's go to the store and find some
ethnic foods for me to redesign
so what i ended up getting
that rice vinegar why did i end up
choosing this uh rice vinegar i think
because one
i like
how minimal the packaging already is
looks a little basic i did some research
online and checked the actual japanese
version and
it's pretty much the same exact
packaging with japanese characters
instead on here so i thought this would
be a good challenge i also like the
marukan logo right here
i thought that was pretty cool already
so it'd be nice to work with that
i'll be using this logo and just
figuring out how to
redisplay all the information that we
see across the bottle now the colors are
really nice i really like the color of
the liquid
in here but when i looked at this on the
shelf it didn't stand out a whole lot
you know i think there's ways that we
can make this look a little bit more
interesting so i did a little bit of
research
so when i first start to design i
usually begin with research so i went to
their website to learn a little bit more
about the history of the brand for me i
was studying what it is that they wanted
to convey through their packaging
through their product and what are some
of the important points the process and
how the product is made and some of the
key qualities about it so after i did
that research i started to write down a
list of keywords and characteristics
that i thought of especially based off
of the research after i did that initial
brainstorm i moved into looking for
inspiration the thing i love to use
really is pinterest pinterest is a great
place for me to find all kinds of
different references of great work that
other people have done i also like to go
to behance there's tons of great work
that's made for creative and i'm just
pretty much bookmarking anything that i
feel like can resonate or connect with
the brand when i'm doing research on
pinterest and behance i'm also looking
at other products that are very similar
either other rice wine vinegars olive
oil any kind of liquid that might have
something similar i might even look a
little bit into alcohol packaging the
thing with alcohol packaging is the
product is very cheap to make so they
spend a lot of money on the packaging so
usually there's tons of beautiful
examples there online that i could use
as a reference to see how might i make
this package a little bit more expensive
looking we're at 11 23.
spent most of my morning
at the grocery store figuring out what
it is that i need to do
and then i also spent about 45 minutes
to an hour just researching other
packaging saturating my brain
researching about how rice vinegar is
made learned a little bit about the
company
rice vinegar is pretty simple you just
take rice you put it in water and you
let it ferment
for a while and then you strain the rice
out and then it becomes vinegar they
have a pretty rich history going back
360 years so this is very interesting so
there's things about heritage tradition
that i can play off obviously japanese
culture i think there's a lot that we
can do with this i think on the shelf
this was about four to five dollars i
wanna see if i could repackage this and
make it look more like fifteen dollars
or twenty dollars and make it look
really really special
in terms of packaging
after having a pile full of references
now it's time to curate all those things
and draw out some ideas based off of the
things that i was loving
so there were a couple of references
that i really liked and what i was
trying to do is look for the qualities
that i like for some of these particular
references and i started to emulate that
and apply that to what i think could be
this new packaging for the rice wine
vinegar the thing is with these sketches
i'm just trying to look for as many
iterations as possible my goal here is
to exhaust all of my initial thinking
doesn't have to be perfect
all right i spent a little time doing
some sketches
which you'll see here
got a couple things that
you know some i think are decent some
maybe look too high-end or maybe i'm too
influenced by
some of the other like perfume and
liquor stuff
but i think i found a few that are more
appropriate and i like the stuff that
starts to feel a bit more traditional
starts to feel like japanese sake
bottles or even just like
more traditional kind of like pickling
and fermentation process stuff with
these paper tops and strips over the top
that are wrapped with a little tiny
piece of twine or rope so i kind of like
that stuff so this is where i'm kind of
feeling where it captures the heritage a
little bit of the
the traditional stuff but also presents
the wine in a very clean and updated way
so i'm probably going to end up
exploring something like that
it is
12 20 right now i have to go to a
doctor's appointment and also gonna grab
some lunch so now that i've spent all
morning saturating my brain and all the
different options doing some research
and then doing some sketching which i'm
going to take my sketchbook with me i'm
going to see if some ideas start to
ferment in my brain and after lunch when
i come back maybe from two hours from
now just see how my ideas uh shape and
i'll start designing some stuff
back from lunch and the doctor's
appointment i didn't sketch that much
more but
i already kind of saw these i made a few
more sketches
a couple more here exploring some stuff
with maybe some possible illustration
elements i feel like this clear bottle i
thought about a wraparound maybe that's
actually different where it breaks there
and then you see rice vinegar so we'll
see i'm gonna start taking this
into design start taking it
on the computer see if i can get
something done the next few hours
once i have a few ideas that i'm really
liking it's time to move into execution
so for this particular example i started
by looking for some nice high fidelity
mockups the thing is with mockups
mockups can be the key to make your
presentation really stand out so if you
have a beautiful mock-up when somebody
else sees it they feel it's higher
quality it's it's all perception at this
point at first i was thinking of using
this particular mock-up that i found
then i chose this bottle because i felt
it looked a little bit more luxurious i
felt like it had some of the nicer
qualities that i wanted being glass all
the way through with this nice little
wood top for this particular mock-up i
changed the color of the liquid just to
be a little bit more realistic you the
color of the rice wine vinegar and then
i started playing with different thai
faces i was looking at things that were
condensed chunky serif sand serif i was
just auditioning a bunch of different
things in the composition to see what
might feel right and the reason i'm
exploring is to see how it affects my
own personal perception of what a high
quality brand might look like versus
something that might be more inexpensive
and cheap
from there i started thinking about
other elements illustrations that might
be on there i felt like with all the
cleanliness of the silhouette of the
bottle as well as the the clean lines of
the typography i wanted to introduce
something that felt a little bit more
organic to break up the different shapes
that are on the bottle so i found this
cool illustration on a stock site i
thought this was really beautiful a nice
way to
show off the rice stock as an element
that would help convey the contents of
the bottle
next thing i started to continue to play
with the type now that i had a couple of
elements on the bottle i was just
looking at the organization and the
hierarchy of type so i was thinking do i
want rice wine vinegar to stand out do i
want the brand to stand out how am i
going to organize these things so that
the hierarchy is straightforward and
very clear ultimately i ended up
choosing something that was a nice serif
font for some reason when i look at the
serif font especially at a bigger
display size like this it just feels a
little bit more premium there's some
beautiful details and the the weights of
the different strokes of this typeface
and how you can see in the details of
the serifs themselves so with the type i
was looking for a specific hierarchy
here i wanted it to be identifiable very
quickly because i know that this bottle
is quite unusual for rice wine vinegar
so i wanted to make that the primary
read by making that very very big and
having the most contrast so that the eye
can go there first you can read it
whether it's
vertical or horizontal and i started
playing with the other aspects of what i
thought were interesting aspects of the
the brandon product was that it was
organic i think that's very important to
a lot of shoppers and a lot of people
and typically when you put organic on
the bottle you expect to pay a dollar
two more if not more for that same exact
product because there's a little bit
more care and responsibility that goes
into making that product at least that's
the perception so another interesting
fact about the brand that i wanted to
highlight was that they were over 300
years old if something has been around
for over 300 years you know they're
doing something right so i was looking
at it as an aspect to highlight and play
up in the packaging design here
as you can see i ended up exploring
several options here started with one
that i really liked and because i had
the time i started exploring two or
three other options to see how i could
play with a hierarchy how i can see how
things are popping out how details
either come to the foreground or push
and recede into the back
so that's why the other two or three
examples i started playing with the
contrast of the rice wine vinegar type
to make that a little bit more obvious
and ultimately i decided as this one as
my favorite i know the rice wine vinegar
is not the most legible on this one but
i think i love the balance of all the
elements so this is the final outcome
for today here is the before
and here is the after
you can also see i have made some other
options here that you can look through
and i was just playing with hierarchy
how things moved to the foreground how
things move back
but ultimately this one this first one
here was my favorite
so
i just finished the challenge i think
they're pretty decent i mean i could
keep refining them but
i'm pretty tired now it's uh
7 41. i think all in all i spent about
six to eight hours doing the work from
picking up the item from the grocery
store this morning
through
researching and doing some initial
sketches all the way to the final design
so it was pretty fun
it was very challenging it was not easy
kudos to you ladies who took this design
challenge on yourself
it wasn't easy
but i think i'm cutting myself off now
i'm starting to get to that point of
diminishing returns where the designs
are pretty good and the more and more i
tweak it it's not making that much of an
improvement so i'm just gonna leave it
if i get inspired to tweak them again
later maybe i will but i think i'm
pretty happy with where they're at and
i'm just gonna move on with my life so
for all of you guys who are having
challenges designing something
efficiently within a time squeeze or
crunch i think if you have a very clear
process you can tackle any design
challenge within a short amount of time
you're going to spend less time
wandering around and more time making
clear decisions and coming to a good
design solution i hope this video was
valuable to you guys let me know what
you guys think about my process and if
you have any questions about it leave me
a comment below
as always don't forget to like comment
and subscribe because it really helps us
out if you haven't seen it yet don't
forget to check out the packaging
challenge done by the young guns on our
other channel i'll see you guys on the
next one